foreign
[Music]
fans to the opening ceremony of the 2023
Superbad chess Classic held here in
Bucharest Romania this is the beginning
of the grand chess tour season the
atmosphere is absolutely electrifying we
have the best chess players on the
planet right here right now getting
ready for the opening ceremony let's get
a party started
yeah I think the opening ceremony was
quite spectacular clear there's been
lots of efforts by the organizers that
was a
everything you know you hope for there
are speeches that were some singing so
good stuff especially with Gary being
there and all the other great Romanian
sporty people it was a very amazing and
well organized opening ceremony I really
enjoyed it every year now it's
traditional We Gather here in Bucharest
the game has great future because we we
know we have solid supporters that are
making sure that our game will be always
treated as a desserts so it always gives
me a great pleasure to to land in in
Bucharest because I know this is a place
where game is treated I would love to
get treated so well thank you trust fans
the opening ceremony has been absolutely
electrifying everybody was having fun
everybody was relaxed speaking with
their colleagues but you know in the
back of their mind round one was
definitely there we had a lot of fun we
had assignment with the 13th world
champion Gary Kasparov as well as all
the other players it was relaxed but
right now we have the games going see
you guys soon
[Music]